foreign
[Music]
it gets pretty lonely out here
I need to regain the memories that the
cree took for me
you are Carol Danvers the most powerful
person on you
way before you could shoot fire from
your fists
I get in trouble for that I have to see
that about you
but what happens when
I'm finally set free
[Music]
I'll be back before you know it
Lieutenant trouble
when you left
mom passed away
and I got flipped back
they rounded us to investigate
Earthbound anomalies Monica
how you feeling like myself
now I can manipulate wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum I'm very happy
for you where's our daughter yes where
is
oh my God
how do you have this my grandma sent it
to me in the mail have you ever wanted
something so bad
and it actually happened
but it's not as great as you imagined it
I'm Gonna Save the World
and You're Gonna Save the World
we switch places whenever we use our
powers
oh wow
higher further faster
together
[Music]